Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: What I did
yesterday, or Monday,
was to describe to you the
First Law of thermodynamics.
So, let me remind you what the
context was.
We're going to study a system,
that's our thermodynamic
system, and for all our purposes
you can imagine that to be some
amount of ideal gas trapped
inside this piston and cylinder
combination.
We put some weights or maybe
some sand on top to keep the
piston where we want it.
The gas has a certain pressure
and a certain volume and we
represent that by a point in
this diagram.
That defines the state.
That's called the state of the
gas.
On a microscopic level,
the state is very complicated,
right?
There are 10^(23) atoms or
molecules zipping around.
We're not interested in such
detailed properties.
We want to look at bulk
macroscopic properties of which
pressure and volume is a
complete pair.
That's all you need.
I think I reminded you that you
don't need a third axis for
temperature because we have this
equation PV = nRT.
So, if you know P and V,
you don't need temperature as
another variable.
That's called the equation of
state.
You can use this all the time.
Whenever the gas has got a
pressure and volume,
feel free to use PV =
nRT.
Alright, so here's the gas.
And then I want to change its
state, and I explained to you
that unlike particles whose
state can change as fast as you
like,
you cannot change the state of
a gas abruptly because if you
take half the weight off the
top,
the piston will fly off;
there will be a period when the
gas is not in equilibrium.
Different parts of it will have
different densities,
different pressure.
You cannot represent that
complicated state as a point in
this plane.
So, what we want to do is to
make changes which are slow
enough for us to follow.
So, one way to do that is to
take one grain of sand.
Take one grain of sand,
then you lower the pressure a
little bit, the piston will move
up a little bit.
Move up means what?
Bigger volume,
lower pressure,
the gas will come there and
then you can take off another
grain and by making the grain
smaller and smaller,
you can make these dots closer
and closer.
It's going to take you a long
time but in principle you can
make the gas move on some path.
That is a thermodynamic process.
This process is always near
equilibrium.
You never deviate too much from
equilibrium, and it's called a
quasi-static;
that means not quite static,
but as slow as you like,
and it is called reversible.
Reversible means that you can
also go right back to where you
came.
If you took a grain out,
piston expands.
You put the grain back,
piston contracts.
So, you can go down this way or
you can go up this way.
I've just chosen to,
let's say, go down like this.
When that happens,
we want to say the following
thing about the state of the gas
before and after.
At every point in the PV
diagram, the gas has something
called the internal energy.
The characteristic of internal
energy is it's called a state
variable.
And this is a very important
concept.
A sate variable depends on
where you are in the PV
diagram, what your state is.
It does not depend on the
history;
it does not depend on all the
things the gas has gone through
in its life.
If you tell me you are here,
then we may associate with that
point an energy that doesn't
look into the history of that
gas.
That energy is nothing other
than the kinetic energy.
You'll remember that it's 3/2
kT per atom,
N atoms,
that's the internal energy.
You can also write this as 3/2
nRT.
If you count the molecules then
use Boltzmann constant,
or you count the number of
moles then use the gas constant.
It's the same thing.
But nRT is PV,
so if you like,
you can also write it this way.
That shows you very clearly the
internal energy is uniquely
determined by PV,
and P and V
determine the product PV.
So, at each point in this
diagram, the gas is a certain
energy.
But energy is simply that ½
mv^(2) for each molecule.
You add it all up,
that's the total energy.
Okay, so we can write it many
different ways.
Now, the First Law of
Thermodynamics asks the
following question.
If I want to change the energy
of this gas, how can I do it?
There are two ways to change
the energy of the gas,
and the total change in
U,
meaning U at the end
minus U at the beginning,
where these are two nearby
points,
is either the heat input minus
the work done by the gas--Let me
write it as capital PdV.
Sometimes you write it as
∆Q - ∆W.
That's the First Law.
So, you have to take some time
to understand what it says.
Notice from this formula here,
the energy of an ideal gas,
and only an ideal gas because
that's the only thing we are
going to talk about,
is a function only of
temperature.
If you know the temperature of
the gas, you know the kinetic
energy of the molecule,
so if the number is constant,
the energy is determined.
The energy depends only on the
temperature for an ideal gas.
So basically,
when I say how can I change the
energy of the gas,
I'm asking how can I raise the
temperature?
One obvious way is this.
Put it on a hotplate which is
slightly hotter than the gas.
Then the heat will flow from
the hotplate to the gas.
That's called heating up the
gas.
There you don't see anything
happening, right?
It's occurring at a molecular
level.
The molecules in the hotplate
are, on average,
moving faster than the
molecules in the gas and during
the collision;
kinetic energy will be
transferred from the hotplate to
the gas.
That invisible flow people used
to think of as the caloric
fluid, but now we know it's just
molecular kinetic energy
transferred from the molecules
in the plate to molecules in the
gas.
That's this guy.
This ∆W,
the plus sign of the W
is the work done by the gas,
and minus of that is the work
done on the gas.
And that means if you want to
increase the temperature of the
gas, you're also told you can do
the following.
Push down on the piston.
If you push down on the piston,
you are reducing the volume.
∆V is negative,
minus P∆V is positive,
and that'll also increase the
energy of the gas.
Or, if you take a grain of sand
out, and the piston moves
upwards, the gas works against
the environment and it pays for
it through its internal energy
because then P∆V will
be positive and this thing will
be a negative contribution of
the internal energy.
So, there are two ways to
change the energy of the gas.
One is a way you can actually
see by moving up and down the
piston.
You can see somebody moving it.
It's a macroscopic motion of
something you can see.
That's called the work done on
the gas.
Other one is energy transferred
at a molecular or microscopic
level, which is what we call
heat.
And the First Law says the
total change in the internal
energy is the sum of two
numbers.
First one is the heat input and
the second one is the work done.
So, what I did for you last
time was a practice calculation
in which I took a gas here,
went along an isotherm.
That means temperature is a
constant.
That's the meaning of the
isotherm.
And I want to go from some
initial point to some final
point.
So, this volume
V_1 and
pressure P_1.
This is P_2
and V_2,
and I want to find the work
done by the gas during this
expansion.
Well, P times
∆V, you can see,
is really that shaded area here
because it's a rectangle of
height P and width
∆V.
So, P∆V is just the
area under the graph that you
follow.
So, the work done,
the sum of all the
infinitesimal works,
is the pressure as a function
of volume times dV from
the starting volume for the
ending volume.
What is P as a function
of V at a constant
temperature is nRT over
V?
Now, I'm using the factor at
every point PV is
nRT, so P is
nRT over V,
and this is a logarithm and we
all know how to do the integral,
as log of the upper limit minus
log of the lower limit.
So, that's the first successful
calculation of work done.
You can take the gas on any
path you like,
you know.
As long as you knew the
pressure at each volume,
you integrated the function
from the left limit to the right
limit;
that's the work done.
For isothermal process,
it's particularly easy because
the pressure is inversely
proportional to volume,
and you do that integral.
This is the work done.
For example,
if the gas expands to double
the volume at temperature 300
Kelvin, the work done is number
of moles, gas constant,
300 log of 2.
Multiply all those things;
that's the work done by the gas.
If that is the work done by the
gas, we can also say the
following.
The internal energy change is
zero.
Right?
That's the trick question I
told you to watch out for.
If you're going at constant
temperature, you don't change
the internal energy.
So, if the change in internal
energy is zero,
it follows at every step,
∆Q = ∆W.
This quantity we call
∆W.
Therefore, the work done by the
gas is also equal to the total
heat input of the gas.
We indicate that by drawing a
little arrow like this;
it's just the way we like to
show that heat flows into the
gas.
Do you understand physically
what's happening?
You take this gas,
you keep it on a reservoir at
temperature T_1
[T_1 is just
T].
It's stuck at that temperature.
If you take a grain of sand,
gas is expanding.
Normally, when the gas expands,
it does work and if energy will
go down, it'll cool down.
But you're not letting it cool
down because you're pumping in
heat from below,
maintaining at that
temperature.
So, this process you should
visualize as a piston with some
weights sitting on a plate at
temperature
T_1.
You take off a grain of sand,
it moves up a little bit but
you don't let it cool down
because you send in heat from
below,
maintaining it at that
temperature.
For example,
you got this computer air,
right?
You blow air on your keyboard
to blow off the dust.
You know, when you blow the air
out, the can cools down.
It cools down because the
compressed air is working
against the atmosphere as it
comes out and,
therefore, it loses internal
energy and it cools down.
That's because you're not
giving it enough time to absorb
heat from the room.
If you let the air out slow
enough so that in the process of
expansion it tries to cool down
but the room pumps some more
heat,
then, of course,
the can will not cool down.
But, you know,
that's not the purpose of
buying canned air.
You don't want to buy canned
air so you can release it at
room temperature.
You don't care if it cools down;
you just want the gas to come
out really fast.
So, if you don't allow heat to
come in, an expanding gas will
cool down.
Okay, that's also why the
universe cools down.
Process of expansion.
Alright.
So, here's a simple problem
where you can do many things.
You can find the change in
energy from start to finish.
Zero.
Work done you find by
integrating PdV and the
heat input is equal to work done
because there's no change in
energy.
This is all the stuff I did
last time.
I also did a couple of other
topics.
I'll just remind you what they
are.
I said we can define a specific
heat for a gas.
Now normally,
specific heat is the number of
calories to raise one gram or
one kilogram by one degree.
But for a gas,
what matters is not the number
of grams but number of moles.
You have already seen it here.
The energy of the gas is not
proportional to the grams of gas
you have but to the number of
atoms you have or the number of
moles you have.
So, we define specific heat to
be the heat needed to produce a
certain temperature change for
one mole.
We take a mole of gas and you
heat the guy and you see how
many calories do I need to get
an increase of one degree.
But that turns out to be
insufficient.
This derivative does not have a
unique value.
Can someone tell me why it's
not sufficient information?
You remember from last time?
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: In other words,
when I take a solid and I say
find the specific heat,
take one gram of solid,
pump in some heat so the
temperature goes up by one
degree, keep track of the
calories.
You are done.
For a gas, it turns out if you
took this gas in the cylinder
and you pump in some calories,
it's going to try to heat up
and when it tries to heat up,
it may also expand.
When it's expanding,
then some of the energy that
you pump in the form of heat,
some of it's turning into work
to push the piston out.
The part that goes through the
internal energy,
the part that really heats up
the gas,
is now less because you put in
some heat from below,
you lose some heat to the
expansion,
so what goes in to change the
internal energy,
which is what controlled the
temperature,
is less than the heat you put
in.
So, if the gas expands during
the heating process,
there's a certain energy lost
due to work you have to take
into account.
On the other hand,
another person can do the same
experiment of the gas but put a
pin here so the piston cannot
move.
Then, of course,
it cannot do any work and all
the heat you put in goes into
internal energy.
That gas will heat up more
readily.
For a solid,
we don't worry about it because
the expansion of a solid is such
a tiny fraction of its volume
when the temperature changes
that the fact that a chunk of
copper,
when you heat it,
is also expanding against the
universe, against the
atmospheric pressure,
is a negligible effect.
The ∆V is so small for
a solid we ignore it.
For a gas it's very important.
Therefore, for a gas there are
two kinds of specific heat.
In fact, you can define many
definitions.
The two common ones are
C_V,
which is ∆Q over
∆T at constant volume,
and that's how you denote that
in calculus [pointing to the
equation].
The other one is
C_P,
which is ∆Q over
∆T at constant
pressure.
So, let me derive one more time
these two specific heats because
it's worth going over this again
and again.
The key to all of this is the
First Law.
The First Law,
written after transposition,
looks like this.
Let's put ∆Q on one
side and the other stuff on the
right-hand side.
In the first case,
at constant volume,
there is no P∆V term
because ∆V is zero.
Therefore,
∆Q/∆T =
∆U/∆T,
and for one mole,
you remember U is 3/2
nRT but n is 1,
for one mole.
So, dU/dT is a simple
derivative of this function with
respect to T, which is
3/2R.
What do you notice about this
formula?
It's the specific heat of one
mole of a gas doesn't depend on
what the gas is.
As long as it's a monoatomic
gas, it doesn't matter what the
mono atom is.
It could be hydrogen,
it could be helium;
it doesn't matter.
That's why we like to think
about the molar-specific heat or
specific heat per mole.
You get an answer that's
universal.
If you took specific heat for a
gram, then one gram of hydrogen
and one gram of helium won't
have the same specific heat
because they don't have the same
number of atoms.
But if you count in moles,
the beauty of the formula is
this number is true for all
ideal gases,
whereas if you took the
specific heat of copper or
silver or iron,
it varies from material to
material.
Specific heat of ideal gases is
very simple.
You don't need to look at a
table.
Here's the answer for all ideal
gases.
It's very important it's a
monoatomic gas,
which is a point-like atom
which only moves but doesn't
have any internal structure so
it can spin and rotate and
vibrate.
If it can do that,
there are other contributions
to energy, but we're not going
there.
Now, let's calculate
C_P.
C_P is
∆Q over ∆T at
constant pressure.
So now, you cannot ignore this
term.
So, ∆U,
from what I did before,
will be C_v
times ∆T,
plus there is a new term.
P∆V is ∆ of
PV because P is
constant.
If P is a constant,
the change in PV is the
same as P times change in
V.
But PV = RT,
so if C_v
∆T plus R∆T.
If you divide every side by
∆T and take ∆Q
over ∆T,
then C_P will
be C_v plus
R and that's a very
famous formula.
And you should understand why
specific heat at constant
pressure is more than specific
heat at constant volume.
Think about that.
If the gas is stuck at a given
volume, it's easier to heat it
up because all the heat goes
into internal energy.
If it is at constant pressure,
you're letting the piston move
up and some of the heat is being
paid to move the piston,
only the rest is going to
change the internal energy.
That's why C_P
is always bigger than
C_v,
and for an ideal gas,
C_P is
C_v plus
R and this number,
γ, is defined as
C_P over
C_v.
This is always the definition
of γ,
where there is an ideal gas or
not.
For an ideal gas,
we can calculate
C_p over
C_v,
which is 3/2 R plus
another R,
divided by 3 /2 R,
which is 5 over 3.
So, γ is not always 5 over 3.
You should be aware of that.
But for ideal gas,
γ is 5 over 3.
So, this is a review of what I
did last time,
but I'm very eager that you
guys should be on top of this
and it's worth doing it one more
time.
But now, I'm going to consider
some more processes where I want
to find work done.
So, maybe I'll start fresh here.
Let's take the following
process.
I start here.
I go on an isothermal here
[pointing at graph],
then I go backwards at constant
pressure until I'm right below
this point, then I go straight
up.
You can ask,
"What is the work done in this
process?"
The work done in the curvy part
of it is all of this.
That's in the part AB.
In the part BC,
work done is the area of this
rectangle but it's counted as
negative, because a gas is being
compressed.
Or, if you like,
it's at some constant pressure
but the change in volume is
negative for every step.
So, even though the work done
is said to be the area,
you've got to keep track of
sign.
If you're compressing the gas,
P∆V is negative.
Therefore, in the part
BC, we must take away the
shaded region and CA,
no work is done because volume
is not changing.
Area under the vertical line is
zero.
So, you can see that in this
full cycle, when I go from
A to B to C
back to A,
the work done is the area
enclosed by the loop in the
PV plane.
That's a very useful result.
We say the work done in a
cycle, there's a symbol we like
to use.
This curly thing on the
integral means taken around a
closed loop.
But you guys have to be little
careful when you write this,
because somebody else can do
the following thing to gas,
do exactly the opposite.
Come down like this,
go down like this,
and go down like that.
Go up like that.
The opposite way.
In this case,
the work done is considered
positive because the part of it,
AB,
is taller than the BC at
point Y,
so the net work is positive.
Here, it's the same amount of
work but the net work is
negative.
So, you've got to be careful
that you describe the sense in
which you do the loop.
So, the same loop,
as a geometrical figure,
as the same area,
but the work done by the gas is
positive in this case and
negative in this case,
and you can use common sense to
find out if it's positive or
negative.
But here is another very
interesting result.
Let's go to the full cycle and
ask, "What's the change in U?"
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Right.
His answer was PV is the
same.
And more generally,
even if it's not an ideal gas,
it's a gas made up of whatever
you like.
It's any system.
If you return the system back
to the same state,
the internal energy returns to
that value.
That's what I meant by internal
energy doesn't depend on the
history of the gas.
For example,
you can take the cylinder,
you leave it alone,
I measure the energy,
I go outside the room and come
back.
In the meantime,
you took it on a loop and
brought it back.
I will not know,
and I don't care because as far
as I'm concerned,
if P and V are
back to where they are;
the gas is back to where it is;
energy is back to where it is.
So, the change in the internal
energy is zero.
That means the work done and
the heat input are the same.
So, let's be very clear.
If you guys do problems,
I don't want you to lose points
for sign mistake.
W is always the work
done and Q is always the
heat into the gas.
So, this is a gas here which
has done some work and some heat
that's been put into the gas,
and the two have to be equal
because the energy doesn't
change in the end.
Now, that leads to a very,
very subtle and interesting
point.
There is a very clear notion of
what is the energy in the gas.
There's a unique answer.
There's no notion of what is
the heat in the gas.
You look at a gas and you
cannot say this is the heat in
the gas.
That makes no sense.
Try to understand why.
Because if you say there's some
amount of heat in the gas,
okay, whatever you want,
some number,
I do the cycle and I come back
to exactly where I am.
I'll put in some amount of heat
Q, which is non-zero.
So, if there's anything called
the heat in the gas,
it has changed by an amount of
Q.
That's why there's no notion of
heat in the gas or work in the
gas.
There's only energy in the gas.
A state variable returns to its
original value and when you go
on closed loop,
the change should add up to
zero.
That's not true for work,
that's not true for heat,
but it's true for the
difference.
That defines an internal state
variable.
Okay, now I'm going to consider
a new process which is of
special importance.
So, the processes I've
considered so far are
isothermal, at constant pressure
is called isobaric,
and I don't know the name for
constant volume,
but no work is done at constant
volume.
Now, I'm going to consider the
last process very,
very important.
It's called adiabatic.
Adiabatic process is in which
the gas changes its volume but
it's completely thermally
isolated, so ∆Q is
zero.
You wrap this guy in a blanket
and you do things to it.
No heat can flow into the gas
or out of the gas.
That's called an adiabatic
process.
Isothermal is quite different.
Isothermal, you keep it on a
hotplate at a given temperature
and as the volume changes,
say as the volume increases,
heat comes in from below.
Or, when you compress it and
you don't want it to heat up,
heat is rejected below.
But this is not the case here.
In an adiabatic process,
if you let the gas expand you
thermally isolate it from
everything.
So, you should think about
what'll happen to a gas if I
start here.
That's what isothermal is.
What do you think will happen?
So, let's draw a few isotherms.
This is temperature,
say T = 300.
This is T equal to what?
More than 300 or less than 300?
Student: Less.
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Less.
And why do I say less?
You take any point here;
it's got the same volume but
lower pressure,
so P times V is
less.
So, this may be T = 200.
If I start here,
now I let the gas expand
adiabatically.
That means I pull out the
grains of sand,
the gas expands against the
atmosphere, but no heat is
allowed to come in.
Think about what that means.
Gas is pushing the piston.
Gas is doing some work.
It'll pay for it through its
own internal energy.
Internal energy will go down
and that means temperature will
go down.
So, what you will be doing is
you'll be cascading down from
one isotherm to another,
plummeting down in temperature
until you come and stop
somewhere at the lower
temperature.
So, an adiabatic process will
cross from one isotherm to the
next to the next to the next,
changing temperature.
Another way to say this is that
the drop in pressure for a given
drop in increase in volume,
it would be more precipitous
for adiabatic because it's
expanding but there's no energy
coming into the form of heat so
pressure drops more
precipitously.
So, it won't be PV equal
to constant, and the question
is, "What is it?"
What is the equation for an
adiabatic process?
What is P as the
function of V?
That's what we want to ask now.
So, whenever you have any such
question in thermodynamics,
up to this point the only law
we know is the First Law of
Thermodynamics.
So, you have to go back to that.
So far, I've driven home the
point that every question asked
in mechanics can be traced back
to Newton's Law.
There are no new laws.
But when you come to
thermodynamics and you study
heat and temperature,
there is new stuff and the
First Law of Thermodynamics is
called a law,
because there is no way you can
derive it from Newtonian laws.
It's a new concept.
So, let's ask what is P
as a function of V,
given that ∆Q = 0?
So, what's our strategy going
to be?
How would you even begin this?
Do you have some idea of what
you might do?
This is a tough question so
even if you give a wrong answer,
that's fine.
How do I calculate the relation
of P to V given
that ∆Q = 0?
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Okay.
Let me write down everything he
said.
When I said ∆Q = 0,
your first reaction has to go
back to the First Law and write
∆Q as ∆U +
P∆V,
and set that equal to zero.
But ∆U is
C_v times
∆T, plus P∆V
is zero.
By the way, ∆U is
C_v ∆T for
one mole.
I'm going to consider one mole
of gas.
Now, this is another thing you
people should understand.
The way in which pressure falls
for temperature is going to be
the same, whether I consider one
mole or two moles or ten moles.
The rate at which it changes
will not be dependent on how
many moles I took,
so if you want you can take
n moles and put an
n here.
You'll find everywhere an
n will come and cancel
out.
Now, P is nRT
over V.
So, maybe I'll do it this way
for you guys.
If you want,
put an n back there,
but you will find n
cancels part of the equation
because nC_v
∆T,
plus nRT ∆V over
V equals zero;
so the answer doesn't depend on
how many moles you took.
So, I will take one mole for my
calculation.
Think about what this says.
Divide everything by T.
You get C_v
over R∆T over T
plus ∆V over V
is zero.
This is telling you that as you
change your volume and you're
coming down this graph of
adiabatic expansion,
when you go from there to
there, there's a change in
temperature such that the change
in temperature by the
temperature,
plus the change in volume
divided by the volume,
should add up to zero.
That is a condition of no heat
flow.
So, it relates a change in
T to a change in
V.
What I would have ideally liked
is a change in P due to a
change in V,
but what comes more naturally
is a change in T over a
change in V.
But let's worry about that
later, because we've got PV =
RT.
We can always swap the
temperature for pressure in the
end.
So, let's just take this
definition.
So, every change,
remember now,
you understand you go from one
point to the neighboring point;
there's a plunge in temperature.
That's why ∆T will be
negative and ∆ will be
positive and these numbers will,
of course, cancel.
Now, let's add all the changes.
Let's call it doing the
integral.
Do the integral of that from
start to finish,
do the integral of that from
and that integral of zero is
just zero.
So, this tells me
C_v over
R times log of
T_2 over
T_1,
plus log of
V_2 over
V_1 is zero.
Now, you've got to go back and
think about your logarithms and
realize--and I can write it as
log of T_2 over
T_1 raised to
the power C_v
over R,
times V_2 over
V_1 is equal to
zero.
We just combine all the
logarithms and realize the log
of X to the power
n is n log
X.
So, that is the same as this.
Now, the log of something is
zero means that something is 1,
because log of 1 is zero.
So, we rewrite the final
expression I got up there by
saying T_2 over
T_1 raised to
C_v over
R times
V_2 over
V_1 is equal to
1.
And we usually write it as
follows.
We say T_2
raised to the
C_v over
R,
V_2 to the
power of 1 is
T_1 raised to
the C_v.
I'm sorry, T_1
raised to C_v
over R times
V_1.
So, this is the relation
between the temperature and the
volume.
Yes?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: You could do that.
That's correct.
You could write down
three-halves if you like.
At the moment,
I'm trying to keep it general.
If it was a gas for which
C_v was not
three-halves R,
all of this would still be
true.
But he is quite right.
For an ideal monoatomic gas,
C_v over
R would be just 3 over 2.
So, what it's telling you is
that when the gas expands,
the temperature falls.
I already told you that.
It's telling exactly how it
falls.
It tells you that T to
some strange power times
V is constant during the
process.
Now, if you want to know what
happens to the pressure,
you can do the following.
You remember PV = RT.
There are many ways to write
this.
I'm going to write it in
another way and you guys see if
you can follow this.
T_2V
_2 to the power
R over
C_v is equal to
T_1V
_1 to the power
R over
C_v.
You believe that?
That's just a mathematical
trick.
If that is true, this is true.
You know how I went from here
to here?
How did I go from here to here?
Do you have an idea?
Student: You take
R over
C_v to the
power of [inaudible]
Professor Ramamurti
Shankar: Exactly.
Raise both sides to the power
R over
C_v.
It's cooked up so that
C_v over
R goes away and R
over C_v falls
on V_2.
There is another way to write
it, if you like.
I'll tell you why I write it
this way.
Because T_2 is
just P_2V
_2.
But let me combine that one
V_2 with this
and write the one plus R
over C_v.
Then, I can show it as
P_1V
_1 to the power 1
plus R over
C_v.
You may object that PV
is not T but is
RT, but R will
cancel so I didn't bother with
that.
And this--don't draw the box
around this yet.
I will write it in a way that's
very, very standard and if you
remember in your high school
days,
you may remember is written as
P_2V
_2 to the
γ,
is equal to P_1V
_1 to the
γ, but γ is just
1 plus R over
C_v,
which you can see is equal to
C_v plus
R over
C_v and that is
C_P over
C_v.
So, this γ is really
C_P over
C_v.
For an adiabatic process,
P_2V
_2 to the
γ is P_1V
_1 to the
γ.
That's one way to write it,
but I will also expect you to
know that you can also write it
in terms of temperature,
as temperature times volume
raised to a strange power is
equal to a constant,
before and after.
Any questions?
So, what we have done is found
pressure as the function of
volume on an adiabatic curve.
So, I'm now going to do one
last ingredient for the rest of
the stuff, which is the
following.
I'm going to calculate the work
done in an adiabatic process
from here to here.
This is one, this is two.
This is not an isothermal,
which looks like that,
it's an adiabatic process.
What's the work done in
adiabatic process?
So, let's calculate that.
Work done is equal to integral
P(v)dV.
But remember,
PV to the γ is a
constant.
Do you guys understand the
relation of writing PV to
the γ equal to constant?
It's the same as saying
P_1V
_1 to the
γ is P_2V
_2 to the
γ.
That means you can pick any
point on the path and P
at that point times V at
that point to the power of
γ will be a fixed
number.
That number is C.
In other words,
this C can be
P_1V
_1 to the
γ if you like,
or P_2V
_2 to the
γ if you like or
P_3V
_3 to the
γ if 3 is another
point on this trajectory.
It's convenient to call that
invariant product of PV
raised to γ as C.
Because then we can do the
integral as dV over
V to the γ with a
constant C here from
V_1 to
V_2.
And this is a pretty simple
integral.
You guys know that the x
to the n integral is
x to the n plus 1
over n plus 1,
such that V to the
γ minus 1,
over γ minus 1.
Because this is really V
to the minus γ.
Now, did I get it wrong here?
I think I got it wrong.
Sorry.
It's 1 minus γ,
1 minus γ,
over 1 minus γ.
Because V to the minus
γ dV,
is equal to V to the
minus γ plus 1 over
minus γ plus 1.
Right?
x to the n
integral is X to the
n plus 1 over n
plus 1, n happens to be
minus γ here.
Okay, now watch this.
This constant I said can be
written as any of these numbers,
but let me write when it
multiplies this;
let me write as
P_2V
_2 to the
γ.
Can you see what happens if I
do that?
Try to do this in your head.
C multiplies all of this.
When C multiplies this
guy, let me write the constant
as P_2V
_2 to the
γ;
that gives me a
P_2
,V_2 to the
γ combines with
V_2 to the one
minus γ,
to give me just
V_2.
Likewise, C multiplying
this one, when the same C
multiplies this,
let's write C as
P_1V
_1 to the
γ,
and we'll find there's that.
And people like to rewrite this
by changing the sign everywhere
as P_1V
_1 minus
P_2V
_2 over γ
minus 1,
because γ minus 1 is
the positive quantity.
So, this is the work done in an
adiabatic process.
So, what's been going on?
Let's think about what I've
been doing.
I told you that there is a new
process called adiabatic,
a really important process,
in which the system is not
allowed to exchange heat with
the outside world.
∆Q = 0 is a condition
relating ∆U and
P∆V.
And the changes are correlated
and the effect of adding up all
the changes, namely doing the
integral,
is this one,
namely temperature to the
C_v over
R times
V_2 does not
change along the path.
So, if you take any two points,
that combination of temperature
and volume doesn't change.
Then, since PV equal to
essentially T,
you can also write it as
pressure times volume to the
power of γ doesn't
change.
So, I'm saying you can call all
of that equal to some constant
C.
The C is not a universal
constant, like velocity of
light.
For a given gas,
on a given experiment,
it does not change as it goes
through adiabatic expansion.
So, don't think of it as a
universal constant.
On the trajectory,
on the adiabatic curve,
it's a constant.
It's like saying kinetic energy
plus potential energy is a
constant.
It's not a constant you can
look up in a book.
It depends on what your
particle is doing.
But for that particle in those
conditions, kinetic with
potential adds to a particular
constant we call total energy.
Likewise, PV to the
γ is a constant for this
particular gas.
Okay, so all this is actually a
preparation for something else.
And that's what we are going to
discuss now.
So, between now and the end of
this course we are going to
discuss the Second Law of
Thermodynamics.
So, we have done all we want to
do with the First Law.
So, you guys should be able to
be given various graphs on the
PV plane,
find the work done in going
from here to there,
find the change in internal
energy,
find the heat added and so on.
I hope you can do such
problems, but they're all going
to be one of these formulas.
Say there's going to be
adiabatic or constant pressure
or constant temperature,
so you just plug the numbers
in, keep track of the signs by
using common sense.
Alright.
So now, we come to the last
part of thermodynamics,
which is to me one of the most
beautiful parts of
thermodynamics,
which starts out with asking
the following question.
There are certain things in
this world that are perfectly
allowed but don't seem to
happen.
Let's take many examples.
Take the Joule experiment.
You take a cylinder of water
with a paddle that can spin and
you put some weight around the
pulley and the weight goes down.
Paddle spins;
the water heats up.
You take a movie of that,
and the movie is so fine it can
even catch individual molecules.
Now, you play the movie
backwards.
So, you watch the movie being
played back and what do you
find?
Suddenly, the weight starts
moving up, paddle spins the
other way, and the water cools
down.
This is not in violation of any
of the laws you have learned
including the First Law of
Thermodynamics,
because when the weight went
down and the water heated up,
some amount of work was done on
the water,
and the energy of the water
went up.
In the reverse process,
the energy of the water went
down and instead the weight went
up, so work was done by the
system.
But that doesn't seem to happen.
If the weight comes down you
can wait all day.
Well, let me give you another
example.
Take a chunk of wood,
you slide it there.
Sorry.
It was not a piece of wood and
it didn't stop.
See, this is why I don't do
demonstrations because even the
simplest demonstration I have
done doesn't work.
So, that's why some of us
become theoretical physicists.
I did a demonstration where
some trolley is supposed to
shoot a little marble.
All the marble had to do was
come down and even that didn't
work, so I don't do
demonstrations.
Well, let's try this.
Here's an eraser,
and give it a push and it
stops.
Take the movie of that.
Play it backwards.
You will find suddenly,
you know the table heats up a
little bit due to friction.
The table can cool down and the
eraser can move backwards
picking up speed [laughter].
Right.
So, why did we laugh?
You have no reason to laugh
right now because it doesn't
violate anything you have
learned,
other than your daily
experience, because in the
reverse process every atom,
you know, every atomic thing on
the desk that started moving,
is made to stop,
turn around,
and move in the backwards
direction.
And every collision between
atoms on the desk and atoms on
the eraser will obey all the
laws of mechanics.
For example,
if you have a planet going
around the Sun,
if you stop the planet and you
reverse the velocity,
it will go the opposite way and
the opposite motion is in
complete accord with Newton's
laws.
In fact, there may be somewhere
a solar system where the planet
actually goes the other way.
It doesn't violate anything.
So, in all the movies which are
played backwards,
at the very microscopic level
there's nothing that says it
cannot happen,
and yet it does not happen.
Here's another thing that does
not happen.
I take a box and I put some gas
molecules on one side and
there's a partition holding them
in that side.
Then I remove this partition
and I wait a little bit;
then I know the gas fills up.
That's like perfume leaking out
of the bottle.
Now, take a movie of these
molecules.
When they go from here to here,
and play the movie
backwards--What'll happen when
you play the movie backwards?
Let's say this guy was moving
like this the instant we played
the movie back.
Well, in the backwards movie it
started going the other way and
slowly the whole thing will
untangle itself and end up here.
That also will not happen.
We all know that if you go to a
room and you release some gas
from one side,
it can fill the room but it's
not ever going to come back,
and yet it doesn't violate any
laws because if I made a movie
and played it backwards,
in every microscopic
interaction between molecules,
there'll be no violation of any
of the laws of nature.
But that doesn't happen.
Here's another thing that
doesn't happen.
I take a chunk of some hot
copper and I take a chunk of
some cold copper.
Hot, cold.
I just put them on top of each
other, come back in an hour,
it's become,
say, lukewarm.
That's fine.
But now maybe,
if I wait long enough,
the lukewarm will automatically
spontaneously separate into hot
and cold.
That doesn't seem to happen.
The heat simply seems to flow
from hot to cold but never back
from cold to hot.
But flowing from cold to hot
will not violate the Law of
Conservation of Energy.
As long as the same number of
calories go from cold to hot,
it doesn't violate anything.
And that doesn't seem to happen.
So, this can go on and on and
on with some large number of
things that are allowed but
don't happen.
So, we cannot explain them with
any known laws of physics so we
elevate that to a new law.
The new law will say these
things cannot happen.
But you don't have a law that
says these things cannot happen,
right?
That's not a good enough law.
You've got to say what things
cannot happen.
I've got a list a mile long.
Hot and cold,
when mixed, will never separate
back into hot and cold.
A gas, that genie that got out
of the bottle,
won't go back,
there's gas that came out won't
go back.
There's a whole lot of
processes which we call
irreversible.
They never seem to happen
backwards.
They only happen forwards,
and we cannot list all of them.
So, you wonder if there's any
law--see, anytime you cannot
explain something from prior
things, you elevate that to a
law.
But you like an economical law.
You would not like a law that
says the following million
things cannot happen.
And it's really amazing that
there is one law,
a single law,
that not only is qualitative,
but is quantitative,
that tells you exactly when
some things can happen and when
some things cannot happen,
and according to the one single
law, all the things that we say
don't happen won't happen.
Will be forbidden by the law,
and that's a Second law of
Thermodynamics,
but what form does it take?
Well, we will see it introduces
a certain quantity called
entropy, about which let's say
right now we don't know
anything,
and the law will simply say the
entropy of the universe will
always increase.
You don't have to write it down
now.
I'm going to define the concept.
It'll arise naturally from more
thinking.
The one law that entropy will
always increase,
in the universe as a whole,
is enough to forbid any of
these forbidden processes.
In other words,
if the paddle spun the other
way and the weight went up and
the water cooled down,
you can show the entropy of the
universe would have actually
gone down.
That's why that's not allowed.
If you drop a piece of egg,
it comes and splatters all over
the floor.
If it rejoined and rose back to
your hand, it won't violate any
other principle other than the
law of entropy,
because the shattered egg has
more entropy than the egg that
comes back to your hand.
And if hot and cold mix to
become lukewarm,
you can show the entropy goes
up this way,
but if you went the other way,
entropy will go down and that's
now allowed.
So, one great law will take
care of all these things.
So, you've got to ask yourself,
"What is the one great law and
how do we get to it?"
Well, it turns out this great
law was discovered by an
engineer called Carnot.
So, here is another thing.
People don't wake up and say,
"I'm going to discover a great
law."
People just go out and do their
business and all you need is
have enough sense to realize
when you've stumbled on
something really great.
So, Carnot had a very practical
question.
Carnot was working on engines.
At the time they were working
on something like the steam
engine.
So, a steam engine--You know
what happens in a steam engine.
You take some coal,
you set fire to it,
then you boil some water,
it turns into steam,
then the steam pushes the
pistons and the wheels turn and
the train goes forward and
that's your steam engine.
What happens in a steam engine
we can schematically as follows.
There is a hot reservoir
T_1 that's the
furnace of your steam engine.
Then, you have an engine in
which you've got some steam.
You've got some water that's
going to be boiled and it's
going to boil only because you
take in some heat.
Here's my engine,
it's got some substance inside,
it could be a gasoline engine
or a steam engine,
we don't care what happens.
Some amount of heat
Q_1 is taken
from a hot reservoir and some
amount of work is delivered.
Now, here is an engine which,
as drawn here,
doesn't violate any of the laws
of physics, provided
Q_1 = W,
then energy is conserved.
In practice you find that's not
how engines work.
The engine also rejects some
amount of heat
Q_2 to a lower
temperature
T_2.
The lower temperature,
if you look at a steam
engine--if you've gone--Have you
guys seen a steam engine?
Okay, if you really go see a
steam engine you will find
there's a lot of hot steam
coming out of the back or in a
car,
you've got exhaust gases coming
out.
That's the hot gas emitted at
atmospheric temperature.
Inside the engine is a very hot
place.
So, the car emits some heat at
a lower temperature.
The steam engine emits some
steam at a lower temperature.
So, the work that you can get
is really Q_1 -
Q_2 is what you
can get.
At least in this engine,
you get Q_1
and -Q_2.
So, we define a quantity called
efficiency η.
It's called the efficiency.
It's what you get divided by
what you pay for.
You pay for burning the coal
and you get the work out.
The work is,
of course, the thing that makes
the engine move forward.
Turns into kinetic energy of
the locomotive.
That, then, you can see is
Q_1 -
Q_2.
What you get divided by what
you pay for, you can write it as
1 minus Q_2
over Q_1.
So, in every engine,
some heat is taken in.
Some of it is converted to work
and some of it is rejected.
To the extent heat is rejected,
the efficiency is less than 1,
because Q_2
minus--over Q_1 and is
subtracted from 1.
So, you can ask yourself why
not build an engine in which you
just don't reject any heat
downstairs?
Why not take all the heat and
convert it to work?
So, Carnot gave a great
argument on the most efficient
engine you can build.
In other words,
there is an upper limit to the
efficiency and it's not 1.
So, what is it and how are you
going to find out?
Well, he's going to find out
what it is, but he also needs a
postulate.
Carnot's postulate is the old
version of the Second Law of
Thermodynamics.
He didn't talk about entropy.
You can show in the end they're
all equivalent,
but Carnot's law,
which is his own version of the
Second Law, which says the
following.
So, Law 2 according to Carnot.
Let me just draw a figure;
then, we'll say
T_1 is not
allowed.
Carnot says you cannot build an
engine whose sole effect at the
end of the day is to transfer
some heat from a cold body to a
hot body,
whose sole effect--that's very,
very important.
You cannot have a process whose
sole effect is this.
I mean, I don't feel like
writing what this is.
It's what the picture says.
All right, it doesn't take a
genius to have the heat flow the
other way.
You understand?
If you want heat to flow from a
hot body to a cold body,
that's trivial.
Just connect them with a metal
rod and it'll flow.
The sole effect of that is
transfer of heat from hot to
cold.
That's the way of the natural
order of things,
but Carnot is saying you can
never build a set of gears and
wheels and teeth and whatever
you like so that at the end of
the day,
all that has happened is heat
has flowed from cold to hot.
That is going to be taken as a
postulate, and people are
willing to take that as a
reasonable postulate,
and we want to see what we can
get out of that postulate.
It turns out it is that
postulate that's going to
control the efficiency of heat
engines, put a bound on the
efficiency of heat engines.
So, don't deduce this.
This is a law.
Now, you might say,
well, this is how the law
began, and the law assumed more
and more sophisticated forms,
so Carnot was not thinking
entropy.
That came later,
but his postulate was,
please grant me this,
which seems to be a fact in
nature.
Then from that let me talk
about heat engines and show you
that there is an upper limit to
the efficiency of an engine.
In particular,
the upper limit is not 1.
It's clear to everybody that
the limit cannot be more than 1.
If it's more than 1,
you are taking some amount of
heat and giving even more amount
of work delivered.
That violates the First Law of
Thermodynamics.
Conservation of energy.
But the fact that you must
necessarily reject some heat,
which you cannot use in this
experiment, is the content of
Carnot's result.
So, here is the engine that
Carnot built.
This is called a Carnot engine.
By the way, look,
don't rely on my graphics.
I mean, you have to go look at
just about any book you can find
on the market.
It'll talk about Carnot engines.
So, I'm here to merely tell you
the words and not the pictures.
So, Carnot's engine is like
this.
Take two isothermals,
T_1 and
T_2.
You remember the adiabatic
curves are much steeper.
Draw two adiabatic curves like
that.
Then take a gas from A
to B to C to
D and back to A.
That was the Carnot engine.
So, let's see what we are doing.
In the process AB,
take the piston with the gas in
it;
slowly lift the grains of sand
so it expands to a volume
B at the same
temperature.
Then having reached B,
you thermally isolate the gas.
It's not on top of a reservoir
of temperature
T_1.
It's completely isolated.
Take out even more grains of
sand.
Now, it's expanding without any
energy coming in.
It cools down to
T_2.
This is the point C.
Now, you put the grains of sand
back, but it's still on a hot
reservoir at
T_2.
I mean, the cold reservoir of
Put the grains of sand back,
temperature is locked in at
T_2 until you
come here.
Then, you isolate the gas and
put more grains of sand back
until you come back to A.
Obviously, such a path exists
because of the way isothermals
and adiabatics are in the
PV plane.
That's the Carnot cycle,
and the important part of the
Carnot cycle is that it's
reversible.
It's reversible because at
every stage, when you took a
grain of sand out you can put it
back and you can run it
backwards.
So, it can also run backwards.
The Carnot engine looks like
this.
Here is the engine,
it takes some heat
Q_1 from a
reservoir of
T_1 that
delivers some work W;
it rejects some heat
Q_2,
of temperature
T_2.
This is the model of a steam
engine.
Suppose you run the Carnot
engine backwards.
By the way, the work done by
the Carnot engine is this shaded
region here and it absorbs heat
in the stage AB.
It doesn't have any heat
absorption in the state
BC because it's
adiabatic.
In CD,
it rejects some heat and
DA again,
there's no heat transfer.
So, heat comes in here,
Q_1,
heat is rejected here,
Q_2.
If you run the Carnot engine
backwards, let me show you what
it looks like.
Everything is backwards in a
Carnot engine if you run it the
other way.
Some work is put in here,
some heat Q_2
is taken from the lower
reservoir and the heat
Q_1 is
delivered to the upper
reservoir.
You know what that gadget is.
That's a refrigerator.
So, in a refrigerator,
that's what happens.
You might say hey,
you violated the Second Law.
You have transferred heat from
a cold to hot body,
but it was not the only thing
that happened,
because some compressor
somewhere did some work.
That's certainly allowed.
What is not allowed is to have
it flow from cold to hot with
nothing involved.
The second thing to notice is
the gas, after doing its thing,
comes back to the starting
point.
That means you can do it over
and over and over again.
In one cycle,
the gas has some heat coming
in.
Q_1 heat
rejected Q_2,
some work done,
W,
and it comes back to where it
is and you can go on doing it
many, many times.
That's why it's a useful engine.
If the substance returns to the
starting point,
having done some work in return
for some heat,
you can do it over and over
again.
And Carnot's question was,
"What's the efficiency of this
engine?"
We're going to calculate that
now.
So, the efficiency of the
engine is η,
is Q_1 -
Q_2 over
Q_1.
Or 1 - Q_2
over Q_1.
Well, Q_1 and
Q_2 are pretty
easy to calculate.
Let me tell you why.
In the process AB,
remember isothermal expansion?
The heat input is the work
done, because change in internal
energy is zero.
And the work done,
you remember,
is nRT log
V_B over
V_A.
Similarly,
Q_2,
as a positive number,
is nRT_2
log V_c over
V_D.
Remember, Q_2
here is defined as a positive
number, even though it's the
heat rejected,
so if I want to get a positive
number, I write the log of the
initial over V final,
so I get a--sorry,
V_c over
V_D.
So, the efficiency now becomes
1 - Q_2 over
Q_1,
becomes 1 minus
T_2 over
T_1 log
V_c over
V_B divided by
log--I'm sorry,
V_c over
V_D divided by
a log V_B over
V_A.
Again, if you cannot follow my
script here, you may have to go
back and get the subscript
right.
But don't worry too much about
all the details.
What I want you to know is the
heat input here and the heat
rejected here are all a familiar
quantities from what I did
earlier.
But now, here is the punch line;
η, I claim is 1 -
T_2 over
T_1.
In other words,
I'm saying forget this ratio of
logarithms.
It is just 1.
I will show that to you,
of course.
It's not going to be written
without proof,
but the final answer for
efficiency of this engine is 1 -
T_2 over
T_1.
So, we need to show why
V_c/V
_D is the same as
V_B/V
_A.
Well, I will derive that here,
then for a couple of minutes
I'll talk about it,
then we'll come back and resume
the discussion.
I'm going to show you that
V_c/V
_D is the same as
V_B/V
_A.
I'm going to show that to you.
Then you agree,
if I take the logs then,
the logs will cancel.
How do I know this?
Well, go back and use the fact
that that's an isothermal
process.
That is an isothermal process.
That is an adiabatic process
and that's an adiabatic process
[drawing graph on board].
This is temperature
T_1,
this is temperature
T_2,
this is A,
B, C,
D.
Now, somewhere in your notes is
a formula that in an adiabatic
process, volume A times
temperature 1 to some strange
power,
I don't care what the power
is--it's not going to matter.
It's the same.
Sorry, volume B times
temperature to some power is the
same as volume C,
the same, temperature
T_2 to some
power.
Because in the process of
adiabatic, we have seen
PV to the γ is
constant,
but I told you can also write
it as volume times temperature
to some power is a constant.
So, B and C are
correlated this way.
Likewise, A and D
are connected by an adiabatic
process so you can be sure that
V_A,
T_A, that
happens to be
T_1 ,
raised to some power,
is the same as
V_DT
_2 raised to same
power.
We don't care what the power is.
It's probably
C_v over
R or R over
C_v.
I'm not interested in that.
In fact, if you go back to this
top right-hand corner you can
see it is volume times T
to the power of
C_v over
R.
But it's not important.
The fact that B and
C lie on an adiabatic
curve means that the volume at
B and the temperature at
B,
which happens to be
T_1, and the
volume of C and the
temperature of C,
which happens to be
T_2,
are connected by this result.
Once I write it down for this
adiabatic and this adiabatic,
now divide that by that,
and that by that,
and the point is that
T_1,
to whatever power it is,
cancels top and bottom,
top and bottom,
and I get the result I wanted,
which is V_B
over V_A,
is V_c over
V_D.
Once you put that in,
you get the final result
η is 1 -
T_2 over
T_1.
Now, there are some things you
should know all the time and
something you should know some
of the time,
and something you should've
seen at least once.
The derivation of the result
you should've seen at least once
in your life.
Whether you carry it in your
head or not, I'm not interested
in.
But what have I really done?
I've taken an ideal gas and
taken it over a cycle and I
found out that in that cycle,
the ideal gas does function
like a very primitive heat
engine because it takes some
heat Q_1,
rejects some heat
Q_2,
and does some work given by the
shaded area.
And the ratio of work done to
heat absorbed in the end happens
to be 1 - T_2/T
_1.
It does not depend on the gas.
It depends only on the upper
temperature and the lower
temperature.
Now, the question you can ask
is, "Why are you computing the
efficiency of this really
primitive and stupid engine when
we're interested in real engines
that GM is going to make or some
steamship is going to make or
some engineer is going to make?"
We will show next time that
this efficiency is a theoretical
maximum.
I will show you next time that
no engine can beat the Carnot
engine.
No engine can be as good.
It can be as good but cannot be
better than the Carnot engine,
and that's what makes the
result important.
It's a lot like a relativity
example, but to show you why
time slows down in a moving
frame I took a very stupid clock
where the clock ticks because
light beam goes up and down.
That's not your idea of a
clock, but in that clock,
if you can see why it slows
down,
you know that every clock has
to slow down because all clocks
in a moving rocket must run at
the same rate.
Otherwise, you can compare the
two clocks and find out you are
moving.
Likewise, if you take a very
primitive engine,
but you can show that that
engine is the most efficient
engine,
you are done because that's
going to put an upper limit on
the efficiency.
So, I'll come back and I'll
tell you next time why no engine
can beat this engine and why
hidden in this result is the
notion of entropy.